تنطلق في المانيا يوم الاثنين المقبل اكبر
تدريبات للقوات الجويه في اوروبا منذ
تاسيس حلف شمال الاطلسي وقد قال الجنر
المايكولوم مدير الحرس الوطني الجوي
الامريكي للجزيره ان اولويه هذه التدريبات
العسكريه المشتركه في المانيا هي الردع
وجهوزيه القوات
هذه اكبر حركه تدريب جويه عابره للاطلسين
ننفذها تضم اكثر من 50 وحده معا للوصول
الى قوه جويه متماسكه من سلاح الجو
الامريكي ليتم ادماجها جميعا مع 24 شريكا
دوليا المانيا هي التي تقود العمليه
ولدينا خارج المانيا شركاء دوليون
يشاركوننا للتاكد من انه يمكننا جميعا ان
نكون جاهزين للتشغيل المتبادل بشكل كامل
من اجل الحصول على الاستعداد ثم الردع
الجماعي
من برلين معنا ام راس الجيران الجزيره
عيسى الطيبي هذه اكبر تدريبات للقوات
الجويه عابره
للاطلسي هكذا وصفها الجنر المايكلو مدير
الحرس الوطني الجوي الامريكي في لقائه معك
عيسى
نعم عثمان هذه لربما ان صح التعبير
الرساله التي وصفتها امي غوتمان سفيره
الولايات المتحده في برلين قالت ايضا في
المؤتمر الصحفي هذا الصباح بانها تستغرب
اذا لم يفهم اي زعيم عالمي معنى هذه
التدريبات وفي مقدمتهم الرئيس بوتين وقالت
بان هذه التدريبات الدفاعيه لكن رسالتها
واضحه لموسكو قائد او مدير الحرس الجوي
الامريكي وايضا قائد سلاح الجو الالماني
الذين ايضا جانا معهم مقابلات كلاهما تحدث
بان هذه العمليه نوعيه لماذا لانها اولا
بمشاركه 250 مقاتله من دول النيت وشركاء
تشمل جغرافيا وهذه للمفارقه من التشيك
جنوبا المطله على شرق اوروبا وصولا للهاتف
واستونيا المطله على روسيا وطبعا مركز
عملياتها في هذه المنطقه جغرافيا ايضا
تلعب دورا في هذه المساله الامر الثاني
وهو تعداد الطلعات القاده العسكريون قالوا
لنا بان نحو الفيل طلعه جويه ستنطلق يوم
الاثنين المقبل وبان المشاركين وبان
الجنود
القادمين من الولايات المتحده نحو ثمانيه
الاف او من الاتحاد الاوروبي نحو عشره
وبالتالي هم كما قال رئيس ومدير الحرس
الوطني الجوي الامريكي قال بان الهدف هو
صياغه راس حربه متالفه تقنيا من اجل
الجهوزيه السؤال الاخر اللي طلعناه هل
الرساله موجهه الى اوكرانيا والى روسيا
قال بان
مخطط هذا التدريب كان واضحا منذ بدايه منذ
منذ تاسيسه ولكن ما جرى في يوم غزو روسيا
لاوكرانيا قال بان هناك تغيير في المشهد
الاستراتيجي وبان اوروبا الان كما قال بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تريد بقاء
قواتها ضمن نوعيه مكثفه في الدفاع والردع
الان بدا الحديث على مساهمه اوروبيه
ومساهمه اطلسيه من اجل وضع سيناريو لو
سقطت كييف كما قال لنا احد العسكريين صباح
هذا اليوم السيناريو الذي يريده الغرب
الاجابه عليه ماذا لو سقطت كيف واصبحت
الخاصره الرخوه وهي بولندا تحت مرمى
الرئيس بوتين يقولون بان هذه المحاكاه في
التدريبات
الضخمه هي من اجل الاجابه على هذا السؤال
يريد المشاركون في هذه التدريبات ان تكون
دفاعيا ليس فقط عن اوروبا ولكن عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وايضا ما
وصفهم الضيف الامريكي بانهم بانها ايضا
للشركاء خارج النيت هنا الحديث عن شركاء
خارج الميته لا يقصد فقط بها من تربطهم
علاقات مباشره او تعاون لكن يريد كما قال
ان يستجب الكثير من من القاده الشركاء
والاصدقاء للمشاركه في هذه التمرينات
الطيبي شكرا جزيلا لك عيسى